[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم قالت السلطات التونسيه انها قتل
تسعه من وصفتهم بالارهابيين في ولايه باجه
و ضبطت كميات من المواد المستخدمه في
صناعه المتفجرات في احدث تطور امني تشهده
البلاد يتزامن مع ازمه سياسيه ممتده منذ
شهور نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين مدى ارتباط تطورات الوضع الامني في
تونس بالمسيره السياسيه الحاليه في البلاد
وهل سيسعى الفرقاء السياسيين الى استخدام
اوراق الملف الامني في ساحه الصراع
السياسي
تخوض قوات الامن التونسيه مواجهات منذ
شهور مع عناصر مسلحه تقول انها من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الذي تؤكد الحكومه انه جزء
من تنظيم القاعده ويلعب الملف الامني دورا
اساسيا على الساحه خصوصا في ظل حاله الشد
والجذب الحاليه بين الائتلاف الحاكم الذي
تقوده حركه النهضه والمعارضه وتزداد اهميه
هذا الدور في هذه المرحله حيث تستعد
البلاد للدخول في حوار وطني يامل منه حل
ازماتها السياسيه والامنيه على حد سواء
العمليه العسكريه مستمره في تونس في
مواجهه التحديات الامنيه التي ظلت تلقي
بظلالها على مختلف الصعد في البلاد اعلن
المتحدث باسم الداخليه ان قوات مكافحه
الارهاب قتلت تسعه ارهابيين والقت القبض
على اخرين وصادرت اسلحه وذخائر في خضم
ملاحقتها للمجموعات المسلحه التي قتلت في
اخر هجماتها عنصرين من الحرس الوطني
بولايه باجه شمالي تونس السلطات التونسيه
تخوض منذ شهور عمليات عسكريه متنوعه لضبط
الامن في البلاد وتقول انها تستهدف بئرا
مختلفه من ضمنها منطقه جبل الشعانبي
ومحيطها على حدود الجزائر والتي توصف
بانها تاوي تلك الجماعات المسلحه التي
تمثل تهديدات مباشره لا من البلاد هاجس وا
تزايد اعمال العنف بعد ثوره الرابع عشر من
يناير
بشده على مجمل الساحه التونسيه ويعتقد
كثيرون ان الفراغ الامني الذي تلى اندلاع
الثوره جعل من تونس ملاذا لعناصر من تنظيم
القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي وانما
تعيشه البلاد الان هو من تداعيات ذلك
وزادت الاغتيالات السياسيه التي شهدتها
تونس من التعقيدات الامنيه والتحديات امام
الحكومه التي تؤكد ادراكها لطبيعه الظرف
الامني وخطورته على مسيره البلاد بمختلف
مراحلها وجوانبها وتشدد على ملاحقه
المسؤولين عن الخلل مهما كانت خلفياتهم ال
خطوط متوازيه في الشارع السياسي التونسي
والثقه تكاد تكون منعدمه بين الفرقاء لكن
لا يزال من المؤمل يعني يفضي مؤتمر الحوار
الوطني الذي بدات جلساته التمهيديه مطلع
هذا الشهر الى نتائج تنعكس على مجمل قضايا
وهموم تونس وبينها الامن طبعا اذا نجح
انعقاده حركه النهضه التي تقود الحكومه
تؤكد التزامها بما سيفضي اليه الحوار بين
ما يشكك خصومها في ذلك ويرون ان تصريحاتها
بشان الحوار الوطني واحاديثها عن ملاحقه
المتسببين في الخلل الامني هي لمجرد كسب
الوقت في اطار تحضيرها في الانتخابات
القادمه
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من تونس
كل من احمد الصديق عون الهيئه السياسيه
لجبهه الانقاذ الوطني والناطق الرسمي باسم
حزب الطليعه وايضا اسامه صغير عضو المكتب
السياسي للحركه يلاحظ في كل مره نتعثر
فيها المسيره السياسيه
تظهر هذه الاحداث الارهابيه اقوله
بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم اولا نطرحها معها
شهدائنا شهداء تونس اه شهداء قواتنا
الامنيه الذين يعني يوجهون في هذه الفتره
اه الارهاب ويوجهونه بكل ما يملكون من قوه
من اجل تامين حياه التونسيين تامين حياه
المواطنين يعني تامين المناخ العام الذي
يجب ان يكون مستقرا في تونس من اجل انجاح
المسار الانتخاب الديمقراطي في تونس من
اجل انجاح هذه المرحله والوصول الى
انتخابات نزيهه لا شك انه هذه العمليات
وهذه اه اه الوضعيه الامنيه التي تواجهها
تونس تؤثر بشكل سلبي على هذا المسار ولكن
لا شك ايضا ان قواتنا الامنيه في واقع
الامر في تقدم كبير جدا وهذا دليل هذا انه
في اكثر من مره نلاحظ ان اه مواجهه قواتنا
الامنيه اه بدات يعني اه في اكثر او في
اغلب اه اه اه الحالات في مناطق قبليه
وهذا دليل عن ان هذه ال المجموعات
الارهابيه بدات تنتشر الى هذه اه المخابئ
ولكن قواتنا الامنيه يعني في مواجهه كل من
يرفع السلاح وكل من يواجه الدوله ويجعل اه
اه امن التونسيين في خطر لم تجب على
السؤال يعني الذي هو باختصار مثل ما تفسير
هذا التلازم بين تصعيد العمليات هذه وتعثر
المسيره السياسيه
لا اعتقد انه يوجد يوجد اي تلازم في واقع
الامر قواتنا الامنيه يوميا هي ت واجهته
اه الى ال ال العناصر الارهابيه ليس فقط
في المنطقه التي استشهد فيها يعني عنصرين
من قواتنا ولكن ايضا في في مناطق اخرى
قواتنا الامنيه في واقع الامر يوميا تواجه
هذه العناصر
يعني تحتجز اه اه اسلحه كانت خفيفه او او
او ليست خفيفه اتحا من نوع اخر على الحدود
مع ليبيا على في مختلف المناطق هي تواجه
ايضا وتتقدم في كثير من العمليات الامنيه
حتى في اه الامساك بمجموعه من القيادات
حتى في بعض المناطق الامنيه في واقع الامر
يعني حربنا على الارهاب حرب تونس ضد من
يرفع السلاح في واقع الامر مستمره ويجو
تقوم بها تونس ايضا ب اه نمط جديد لا يجعل
من كل من هو اه اه يعبر عن رايه ب كان في
راي متطرف ديني او غيره ان يكون يعني وجهه
للاعتداء الامني بل وجهتنا هي فقط من يرفع
السلاح ضد الشعب التونسي ضد امن التونسيين
السيد احمد الصديق هل من ارتباط بين تطور
الوضع الامني والمثيره السياسيه برايك
بطبيعه الحال نعتقد جازمين في الجبهه
الشعبيه وفي جبهه الانقاذ وفي حزب الطليعه
العربي الديمقراطي ان تعثر المسيره
السياسيه وانحراف الحكومه الحاليه عن
المهام التاسيسيه واطالتها للوقت وتجاوزها
لمده الشرعيه واستفحال الازمه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه تخلق مناخا خصبا لكل المخربين
الذين يريدون التلاعب بمصير الثوره وتخريب
المجتمع وضرب قيم الجمهوريه ودليلنا على
ذلك حقيقه واضح وهو انه اثرت عبر حلقه
الحوار الاولى في اكتوبر 2011 تم بعد اشهر
اغتيال الشهيد شكري بالعيد ثم بعد التحري
الحلقه الثانيه التي انعقدت في ماي 2013
ايضا تم اغتيال السيد محمد البراهمي شهيد
الجبهه الشعبيه والشهيد الطيار الشعبي وفي
كل مره عندما تدلهم الغيوم و عندما يتعثر
المسار السياسي بسبب الفعلي والمنهج
والسلوك الا مسؤول لحكومه التي لا تريد ان
تعترف لا بفشلها ولا بعثها كلما ازدادت
هذه الازمه كلما افتقد التونسيون الثقه في
المستقبل كل ما تعثرت المسائل الاقتصاديه
وال تمشي الاقتصادي بطبيعه الحال وازدياد
البطاله
يخلق هذا المناخ التي تستغله الجماعات
الارهابيه لتضرب بقوه اعتقد ان اضطرابات
واضح وان حل مشكله الارهاب لا تقتصر فقط
على الملاحقات الامنيه و مداهمتها وتفكيك
خلاياها وهو عمل جبار تحيي عليه الاجهزه
الامنيه وانما يقتضي قبل كل شيء القضاء
على او كارثه والمناخ الذي تعيش فيه هو
مناخ الغموض والازمه السياسيه وانعدام
الثقه وافتقاد الامل في المستقبل سيد صغير
الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تؤثر هذه الظاهره خاصه مع كشف
اسلحه متطوره جديده نوعيه لدى هؤلاء الى
اي حد يمكن ان تؤثر على المرحله
الانتقاليه هذا في تونس
لا شك انه تونس اليوم يعني مترابطه بشكل
واضح وجلي
المنطقه بشكل عام ولا شك انه الاوضاع
الامنيه
اه اه
الموجوده في الدول التي تجد مثلا اخواننا
في ليبيا لاشك انه لها تاثير مباشر على ما
يقع فيه في داخل تونس لذلك الجهد اليوم
جهد كبير جدا في اتجاه محاوله التامين اه
من هذا المسار وهذا يعني في واقع الامر
عام اليوم انا لا اتفق مع مقال الزميل
احمد ولكن في واقع الامر القوات الامنيه
والحكومه يوميا يعني تعمل من اجل اه بجديه
حقيقيه في مواجهه هذه اه من يرفع السلاح
في وجه التونسيين لذلك انا اعتقد انه
بالعكس يعني دورنا كل الاحزاب السياسيه هي
ان تكف على نوع من التطرف ونوع من تحميل
المسؤوليه للطرف الاخر وان وان نتمسك بما
نقوم به اليوم واعلنا اعلان على انطلاق
الحوار الوطني عن قريب اه كانت مس كبير
جدا من المعارضه ان ينطلق اه في في اقرب
الاجال ونحن قبلنا بهذا ولذلك سينطلق
الحوار عن قريب هذا انطلاق للحوار من اجل
ان ان يكون توافق واسعه مع كل الاطراف بين
كل الاطراف والخروج من تونس من هذه
المرحله الانتقاليه والوصول الى انتخابات
تعطي لتونس اه حكومه مستقره تستطيع ان
تواجه اه بشكل اه يعني اقوى اه اه اه كل
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والامنيه
التي تواجهها ولذلك انا اعتقد ان
الحكومه
الامنيه غاضبه الى درجه منعت الرؤساء
الثلاثه في اثناء تشييع قتلى الحرس
اه ما وقع فيه نوع من التسييس تونس تعيش
مرحله مرحله صعبه جدا من مرحله فيها اه
يعني استقلال وحيات وجوب استقلال الوحيد
اه بعض المرافق الوطنيه منها الامن بالذات
يواجه بعض الاشكاليات وهذا دخل في هذا
الاطار توجد يعني مجموعه من
من الامنيين الذين اه يعني ينتمون الى
نقابه معينه هدفها يعني في بعض الاحيان
واضح انه التشويش على مسار انتخاب اه
التونسي وبالتاكيد عن قريب ستاخذ الحكومه
التونسيه اه قرارات من اجل ان اه اه من
اجل الوقوف ضد من اه يعني يهدد خطر
مسؤولين منتخبين في تونس والعله هذا هو ال
النقطه التي تجيب على اه هذا الاشكال انه
يوجد من يعني اه يخطط من اجل يعني الاطاحه
ب من تم انتخابه
المشكله الامنيه برايي
المشكله الامنيه هي سياسيه بامتياز ليس
هناك من جهات امنيه يمكن ان يعمل بحياد
وفي كل ف قيم الامن الجمهوري الذي يقف على
نفس المسافه من الجميع اذا ما كانت وزاره
الداخليه اثر انتخابات اكتوبر وتشكيل
حكومه تريكه قد قادها قيادي حزبي من حركه
النهضه اوغلي في التعيينات الحزبيه التي
بنيت على اساس الولاء لحزب النهضه وليس
على اساس الكفاءه الامنيه هذا ما يقوله
الساده رؤساء النقابات الامنيه هذا ما
تقوله المعارضه هذا ما تقوله الجمعيات
والمراسيم التي تراقب العمل الامني
والقوات المسلحه المشكله سياسيه بامتياز
ومن اوجد في ضرب حياديه الاجهزه الامنيه
هي حركه النهضه مع الاسف نحن اليوم عشيه
حوارا وطنيا نامل ان ينطلق يوم الثالث
والعشرين اليوم الاربعاء المقبل لا يحب ان
منك الجراح ولكن عندما نستمع الى
المغالطات اعتقد ان من واجبنا جميعا وخاصه
المعارضه ان تضع النقاط على الحروف المكتب
الرئيسي والاساسي للنقابات الامنيه واعتقد
انه يقف وراءها بمعنى المسانده دون التدخل
في شانها كل القوى الحيه في البلاد سواء
جمعيات المجتمع المدني او المراسيم التي
تعنى بالشان الامني وتعالى بحقوق الانسان
والطعن بمرفق الامن والامان للتونسيين او
الاحزاب السياسيه وهي بما انها احزاب
سياسيه لها الحق في الاهتمام بالشان
الامني اعتقد ان ما حدث بالامس في العين
رغم كل ما يمكن ان يكون لنا من مواقف
بخصوص ضباط يه وضروره بقيه المؤسسه
الامنيه يدل على ان هناك احتقانا كبيرا
لانه لم يقع مد القوات الامنيه بالمعده
اللازمه لم يقع الالتفات الى مطالبهم او
غيره في التعيينات على اساس الولاءات
الحزبيه دون الكفاءه وهذا كله خلق جوا من
الاحتقان مع استشهاد الشهيدين اللذين
استغل المناسبه لتعزيه الهم
الانحناء اجلالا لهم هو زملائهم ممن سقطوا
ضحايا الغزو الارهاب كلمه اخرى و بعجاله
اقول بان من تتساهل مع خطاب التكفيريين
بان تحالف معهم بما منحهم فرصه السعودي
على منصات ه في اجتماعات الشعبيه واقصد
حركه النهضه من ترك المساجد يعني مفتوحه
لهم لاعلان خطابه التحريري بما فيه
التحريض على قتل منسقه شهداء للجبهه
الشعبيه هؤلاء يتحملون على الاقل حتى يثبت
عكس ذلك مسؤوليه سياسيه مباشره ونحن في
المعارضه وعن مسؤولون عن هذا الوضع الخطير
الذي لا تتحمله لا بلادنا تونس ولا
المنطقه برمتها لذلك ذهبنا للحوار وان
حبينا ان حبينا انحناءه المسؤولين الرجال
الذين يعرفون مسؤوليه هذا الوطن ولذلك
ذهبنا مع من نعتقد بان هم مسؤولون سياسيا
عن الاخوان اللي قلنا نتحاور معهم ونتمنى
ان تنطلق هذا الحوار يوم الاربعاء اذن
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده هل سيكون الملف
الامني في تونس ورقه للاستخدام السياسي ان
تبقى معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش المشهد الامني في تونس وانعكاساته
السياسيه اه سيد اسامه الصغير عضو المكتب
السياسي لحركه النهضه اشار السيد احمد
الصديق الى الثالث والعشرين من اكتوبر
موعد مفترض لانطلاق الحوار لكن اين تكمن
العقده برايك لا سيما ان النهضه متهمه
بانها اه تشتري الوقت بقبولها بهذا الحوار
طالما ان الحكومه لم يعلن الاستعداد
الاستقاله هذه الحكومه والمطلب الرئيسي
للمعارضه
اولا اسمح لي ان اجيب على بعض الاتهامات
التي يقوم بها زميله احمد الصديق وهي يعني
اه خارج عن الحقيقه ولا دليل على هذا
بالعكس حركه الماضي اثبتت انها يعني تبحث
عن الحوار في اكثر من وضعيه في كل الازمات
لم تبحث على الحكم لوحدها بل حاولت في كل
مره ان تجلس مع شركائها وان توسع دائره
الحوار وقبلت بان يكون وزير الداخليه
وزيرا يعني مستقلا فاليوم لا احد يستطيع
ان يتهم حركه النهضه وكل اتهامات باطله
ولا اساس لها من الصحه ولا احد يستطيع ان
يثبت ذلك ابدا يعني حركه النائب عملت من
اجل اه منذ البدايه من اجل اه الشراكه في
الحوار الشراكه في الحكم من اجل الانتصار
طاوله الحوار والابتعاد على الفوضى وعلى
منطقه المغاربه ولذلك انا اعتقد انه علينا
ان نتكلم بكل وضوح كل الوقائع التي صارت
في تونس منذ انطلاق هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه و منذ انطلاق الانتخابات او
نتائج الانتخابات اثبتت حركه النهضه ان
على استعداد دائما للجلوس على طاوله
الحوار
الحكم
عليها وقال انكم خطار التحريض واستخدمت من
ورقه السلفيين والان تقولون هنالك ارهاب
تقدمتم ورقه من يعتبرونه المتطرفين والان
تقولون تعانون من الارهاب اه لم ترد على
هذه النقطه الخطاب التحريضي انت ذكرت في
البدايه بانكم فقط من يرفع السلاح اه اه
تلاحق ونه ليس كيف ما كان الا يفهم ذلك
بانكم فعلا تركتم الخطاب التحريضي
مقاربه حركه النهضه هي يعني انها حركه
سياسيه معتدله وترفض التطرف لذلك نحن نفط
التطرف من كلا الجهتين من يرفع السلاح كان
يعني انطلاقا من من دين او من ايديولوجيا
او فكره معينه
هذا هو الطرف الذين واجهوا لاننا لا نرى
ولا ولا حركه النهضه ليست على استعداد
ابدا بان تمشي مره اخرى دوله الاستبداد
ودوله القمع في اه في في الافكار كلما
كانت هذه الافكار تحترم الاخرين ولا ولا ت
تبعث على العنف نحن اه لا لا لان صادرها
ولا ولا ولسنا مستعدين ابدا من اجل ان ان
اه ان ان نضع حدا لهذه الحريه حريه
التعبير التي اكتسبها الشعب التونسي بكلمه
شكرا لك
هذه التصريحات
طبعا هذه الاسطوانات المشروخه عذرا على
استعمال هذه العباره يجد نفسه مضطرا
لاستعمالها نحن لم انا احمد الصديق
مخاطبكم اليوم رفع في 10 قضايا السلفيه
الجهاديه في تونس لانهم حكموا لمجرد نيه
او التفكير او التعبير عن رايي نحن لا
يتحدث عن ذلك وليس هناك شخص واحد في كل
المعارضه التونسيه يطالب بمحاكمه الراي
هذا كلام بعيد عن الحقيقه وتريد به حركه
النهضه خلق جدار من الغبار ومن الضباب
تخفي به الحقيقه انا اتحدث عن من حرضوا
على قتل التونسيين انا اتحدث عن من كفر
نصف المجتمع انا اتحدث عن اولئك الذين
دعوا الى قتل شكري بلعيد والتسجيلات
موجوده ولم تحرك النيابه العموميه ساكنا
ولم تحرك السلطات العموميه مساكن انا
اتحدث عما ان حرض على حسين العباسي على
احمد الصديق علي محمد ابراهيم قد استشهاده
انا اتحدث عن اولئك الذين قالوا اقتلوهم
انهم يفسدون دينكم هؤلاء ارتكبوا جرائم
منصوص عليها في المجله الجزائيه التونسيه
وكانت سياسه حركه النهضه
تشهد والليل والتغافل عما يصنعون انا
اتحدث عن الذين يجمعون الاموال اليوم وامس
و في السنه الفارطه تحت اعين حركه النهضه
ان اتحدث عن من يتقون الى منصات
الاجتماعات الشعبيه التي تنظمها حركه
النهضه وتحرض الناس على الدفاع عن الاسلام
الذي يهدده العلمانيون الذين يقودهم فلان
وفلان وفلان ما الذي يضمن المتطرف اول
متحمس شاب يعتقد انه يمثل دورا في فيلم
الرساله دفاعا عن الاسلام والرساله
المحمديه ال ال ياتي ليلا الى بلد او الى
يعترف الطريق احد المعارضين الذين سهم
الخطاب التحريضي وكانهم من قبيل
الى السؤال الاساسي الذي طرحته عليك هو
مصير الحوار في الثالثه والعشرين من
اكتوبر لاسيما مع الاتهام للنهضه بانها
تسهر الوقت او انه ربما ليس هنالك راي
واحد في النهضه او ربما ايضا توزيع ادوار
هلا اوضحت لنا الموقف
اه حركه النهضه قبلت ب اه اه مبادره
الرباعي بالنقاط الاساسيه التي توجد بها
وبالاساس بالمصادقه على الدستور المصدق
على قانون الانتخابات والهيئه والمصادقه
ايضا على كامل اعضاء الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات التي ستصل اليه مهمه
اه الانتخابات و بهذه النقاط للحكومه اه
ستستقيل
وسمع الحكومه مستقله
محايده ت توافق عليها جميع الاطراف حركه
اذا لم تتراجع ابدا بل اكدت يعني هذه
النقطه في جميع بيانات وحتى في البيان
الذي يخرج الذي يعني بين تخرج اليوم عن
حركه النهضه فقد ذكرت الجميع بان المده
الزمنيه التي حددتها اه حددها الرباعي لا
تكفي للمصادقه على الدستور والمصدق على
قدوم الانتخابات والتركيز ايضا الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات توافق اه
الامين العام اه
الاتحاد ال اتحاد الشغل اه السيد حسين
العباسي على النقطه هذه نقطه حركه النهضه
ووافق عليها في داخل حوار جميع الاطراف
السياسيه انه لابد من تلازم بين هذه
المهام الاساسيه وبين يعني استقاله
الحكومه ويجب توضيح هذه النقطه ونحن
وضعناه في اكثر من حاله عندما تنتهي هذه
النقاط نحن مستعدون على اقامه حكومه حكومه
مستقله محايده من اجل ان من اجل
الانتخابات والمرور الى انتخابات في اسرع
وقت ممكن ولن تتراجع حركه النقل على هذه
النقطه ولا احد يستطيع ان يثبت ان حركه
النهضه تراجعت في اي من هذه النقاط
الصديق
يسعى الفرقاء السياسيين مشاركون في الحوار
الى اه استخدام اوراق الملف الامني اه اه
يعني للمزايده في مساله ال ال الملف
السياسي بمعنى مثلا هل يمكن ان يخلط
الاوراق بشكل ان لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
مكافحه الارهاب وتاجل استحقاقات الاخرى
اعتقد اننا تجاوز تلك المرحله
واعتقد ايضا انه لم يعد بامكان الحكومه
ولا حركه النهضه ولا حلفائها في الحكم ان
يتلاعبوا بالدم التونسي حقيقه نحن جميعا
ضد الارهاب نحن اشد الناس على الارهاب
اكثر حتى من الحكومه في تفكيرنا في منهجنا
في سلوكنا في نضالنا ونحن اوضحنا الجبهه
الشعبيه دفعت ثلاثه شهداء زعيمين وطنيين
كبيرين العيد ومحمد برامج وزعيم محلي
خسارته ايضا جبهه الانقاذ وهو الذي ينتمي
الى حركه تونس كيف لنا ان نزايد بهذا
الملف اعتقد انه لم يعد هناك وقت لا
للمزايدات واللعب بالاوراق المغمسه بالدم
بل الوقت لان نحن جميعا لدماء الشهداء وان
نتحمل المسؤوليه وانا قبل حركه النهضه
نهائيا وبدون مواربه سمعت كلام مخاطر
المحترم السيد اسامه يقول باننا اشتركنا
وانهم قبله ليست لنا شروط وليست لديكم
شروط هناك خطه طريق واضحه لا تستحق توضيحا
هناك نقطه الفنيه تم حسمها اليوم
في اول جلسه لا نقطه الفنيه تتعلق بهيئه
الانتخابات اليوم الاول في الحوار الوطني
وهو يوم الاربعاء المقبل يتوجب ان تعلن
حركه النهضه وهي اولى النقاط في المبادره
اول النقاط في خطه خارطه الطريق
ونتمنى ان لا تخلو هزه كما فعلت دائما
بوعودها وتنفذ ب ما وعدت به لان بلادنا لا
تحمل مزيدا من الهزه ولا مزيدا من النكول
ال الحكومه بعد ثلاثه اسابيع بالضبط من
انطلاق الحوار الوطني اي بعد ثلاثه اسابيع
من يوم الاربعاء 9 اكتوبر الفين
اخيرا
يعني سبب اه مشاركه حركه النهضه في الحوار
هو انتصار الحوار طاوله الحوار
والوقوف على تجيش الشارع واه الخروج
للفوضى في الشارع ولذلك انا استغرب ايضا
حتى استمرار دعوه جبهه الجبهه الشعبيه لل
مظاهره يوم ثلاثه وعشرين اكتوبر في الوقت
الذي يجب علينا جميعا ان جلسه اه حول
طاوله الحوار اعتقد اننا يجب ان ان نكثف
من التطرف وان كفه من المناداه ال ال
للفوضى ولا
للنزول الى الشارع وعلينا ان تحمل جميعا
مسؤوليتنا ونطبق ما ورد بمبادره الرباعي
اذا استطعنا جميعا اذا كان يوجد توافق
واسع حقيقي من اجل الدستور وقانون
الانتخابات والهيئه المستقله للانتخابات
بالتاكيد سنكمل هذا في ثلاث اسابيع ان لم
نستطع ان نكمل كل هذه النقاط في ثلاث
اسابيع فيمكن نحتاج وقت اكثر والحكومه
ستستقيل فقط ان انتهاء المرحله التاسيسيه
للدستور والقانون
الصغير عضو المكتب السياسي لحركه النهضه
اشكر احنا الصديقه السياسيه لجبهه اللقاء
الوطني و اشكر متابعتكم مشاهدينا بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
فيما وراء خبر جديد فالى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ام